Hola y bienvenidos de nuevo a la serie de cursos sobre el Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Mi nombre es Victoria Lipinska y en este video veremos cómo representar
un problema VQE de manera que la computadora cuántica pueda entenderlo.
Normalmente, un problema de química cuántica se expresa en términos de las energías
del sistema.
Al operador que describe estas energías lo llamamos Hamiltoniano.
Primero necesitamos cuantizarlo.
Es decir, expresarlo en el lenguaje de la química cuántica,
que se conoce formalmente como segunda cuantización.
Si el Hamiltoniano describe interacciones fermiónicas, por ejemplo,
la energía de electrones en orbitales de espín, nos referimos a esto
como Hamiltoniano fermiónico, y será nuestro punto de partida hoy.
Sin embargo, los qubits tienen su propio lenguaje.
Los operadores en el mundo de los qubits se describen mediante los operadores de Pauli.
Así que nuestro objetivo aquí es expresar los operadores fermiónicos
en términos de operadores de qubits.
Existe una correspondencia simple uno a uno entre
los estados cero y uno para fermiones y qubits.
Por lo tanto, el mapeo entre los estados también es directo.
Sin embargo, el mapeo de los operadores es un poco más complejo.
Los Hamiltonianos fermiónicos se expresan con operadores de creación y
de aniquilación.
Así que nuestra tarea es hacer que sea más fácil para una computadora cuántica entender
el Hamiltoniano.
Usaremos herramientas matemáticas para mapear un Hamiltoniano fermiónico
en un Hamiltoniano de qubits con gates.
En otras palabras, vamos a traducir entre
el lenguaje de la química cuántica y el lenguaje de la computación cuántica.
Imagina dos cadenas, una con fermiones,
es decir, en el lenguaje de la química cuántica.
Y una con qubits, es decir, en el lenguaje de la computación cuántica.
A primera vista, el mapeo parece directo, ¿verdad?
En ambos casos vemos sistemas con dos niveles.
Para los fermiones, tenemos o bien un fermión en el estado
o ningún fermión en absoluto.
Y para los qubits, tenemos o bien el estado 0 o el estado 1.
Sin embargo, es más complejo que eso.
La diferencia entre una cadena de qubits y una cadena de fermiones
es algo muy fundamental en física: lo que llamamos simetría de intercambio.
Dos fermiones nunca pueden ocupar el mismo estado.
Sin embargo, para una cadena de qubits, esto es completamente diferente.
Dos qubits pueden estar ambos en el mismo estado,
ya que un qubit no es un fermión.
Ahora debemos encontrar una forma de traducir entre las dos cadenas.
Ya en 1928, dos investigadores, Jordan y Wigner,
demostraron que los operadores fermiónicos para toda la cadena
pueden representarse exactamente en términos de operadores de qubits.
Este es el mapeo más directo para una computadora cuántica.
Por ejemplo, se puede usar para mapear la ocupación
de un orbital al espín de un qubit.
En la práctica, este mapeo para un Hamiltoniano resulta en una suma ponderada de operadores de Pauli.
Este es un hecho muy importante que me gustaría que tuvieras en mente,
y volveremos a esto en el siguiente módulo, donde hablaremos
sobre cómo se ejecutan los circuits variacionales en la computadora cuántica.
El mapeo anterior significa que si tuviéramos, por ejemplo,
14 operadores fermiónicos, mapearíamos el problema en 14 qubits.
Por suerte, existen formas inteligentes de reducir el número de qubits
y usar menos recursos cuánticos para obtener un mejor rendimiento de una computadora cuántica.
Normalmente, en un sistema molecular, conoceremos
algunas simetrías físicas del Hamiltoniano,
por ejemplo, que el número total de electrones es fijo.
Esta información se puede usar para reducir el tamaño del problema
sin perder ninguna información relevante.
A esta técnica la llamamos reducción del espacio activo.
Esto permite reducir el número de recursos, concretamente, el número de qubits,
antes del mapeo de qubits como la transformación de Jordan-Wigner.
Este paso calcula un Hamiltoniano efectivo
y nos permite usar menos qubits como resultado.
Para nuestro ejemplo con 14 orbitales,
esta técnica reduce el número de qubits a solo seis.
Ahora podemos ir aún más lejos con estas reducciones.
Podemos usar diferentes mapeos,
que son un poco más elaborados que Jordan-Wigner.
El ejemplo más común es el mapeo de paridad.
El mapeo de paridad no mapea la ocupación de los orbitales en los qubits,
sino la paridad de los orbitales en qubits individuales.
No entraremos en los detalles matemáticos aquí,
pero lo importante es saber que este mapeo contiene redundancias adicionales
que se pueden aprovechar para eliminar dos qubits más.
Por lo tanto, nuestro ejemplo con 14 orbitales se reduce de 14 qubits
a 6 qubits con la reducción del espacio activo y luego a 4 qubits
con la reducción de dos qubits en el mapeo de paridad.
Mencionemos brevemente una transformación más.
Otro mapeo comúnmente usado entre la representación
fermiónica y la de qubits es la transformación de Bravyi-Kitaev.
La transformación de Bravyi-Kitaev usa qubits para codificar la información
tanto sobre el número de ocupación como sobre la paridad del estado cuántico.
La transformación de Bravyi-Kitaev combina la información de número de ocupación y paridad
para una base de orbitales moleculares de tamaño N,
donde de nuevo se usan N qubits.
Sin embargo, la información almacenada en cada qubit
varía según de qué qubit se trate.
Es decir, cuando el índice del qubit es par,
almacena el número de ocupación del orbital
correspondiente, como en el mapeo de Jordan-Wigner.
Cuando el índice del qubit es impar, el qubit almacena la paridad de un conjunto
particular de números de ocupación. La transformación de Bravyi-Kitaev es la más eficiente
cuando el número de qubits se aproxima a una potencia de dos.
El mapeo de Bravyi-Kitaev combina las ventajas de Jordan-Wigner
y de las transformaciones de paridad.
Reduce el número de qubits sobre los que actúa cada término del Hamiltoniano,
lo cual es importante para la simulación cuántica, ya que los términos
que actúan sobre un gran número de qubits en el Hamiltoniano
requieren circuits más largos para su simulación.
Esto significa que la profundidad del circuit
se reduce con la transformación de Bravyi-Kitaev y, en general,
podemos obtener mejores resultados con el hardware.
Esto supone una mejora respecto a la transformación de Jordan-Wigner,
que resulta en un Hamiltoniano de qubits de orden N.
Así que, en este video exploramos métodos para mapear
un Hamiltoniano fermiónico en un Hamiltoniano de qubits.
En el siguiente veremos cómo seleccionar de la mejor manera el estado
y una forma variacional o un circuit.
Nos vemos allí.